attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
et arts et aux arrêts toi donne moi ton
portable aux attentes et ça me racketter
tu crois je rigole avec tout quoi ah non
non non ou alors c'est vraiment pas
drôle c'est ça les bonnes toiles tulle
pourquoi tu fais ça de tapas de trahi
non pas par de trois missions d'intérim
par ci par là j'ai je galère là pourtant
j'aimerais bien trouver un toit un
travail qui me permet de m'épanouir sur
le dessin la peinture le fusain et tous
les métiers de l'art quoi mais bon là
c'est la merde mais masi donne moi ton
portable ça m'arrange pas mais non parce
que j'ai tous mes numéros j'ai des
photos et j'ai pas fait de sauvegarde
tempêté redoute web les chaussures donne
moi tes chaussures tu vu combien 41
matchs du 46e ne savait trop grand pour
toi ton portefeuille toi devant ton
portefeuille non j'ai pas de liquide
et puis les papiers et toi tu t'en fous
moi je vais être obligé de refaire ça
est une galère non franchement je
préfère qu'on en reste là
mais d'ailleurs pourquoi toute cette
agressivité parce que j'ai pays perd
confiance en moi c'est tout quand
j'étais au collège là j'étais petit et
gros donc tout le monde disait le
pierrot way et du coup j'ai accumulé
tout cette agressivité tu vois en fout
ici là et maintenant je m'en sers pour
faire respecter tu comprends ça et ça
marche avec les vieilles ouais les
enfants un chat mais avec les mecs c'est
plus compliqué c'est bah allez y
messieurs je peux te peu de feeling
clope
bah je fume pas mais bon c'est toujours
ça de pris quoi aidera tu vas faut que
je gagne en assurance tu vois déjà
redresse toi voilà les bleus menton - ah
ok j'ai compris qui donne moi ton porta
piste de [ __ ]
voilà on y est après tu peux faire des
alternatives il peut ne pas y avoir
baissé les yeux
ah ouais ouais parce que les yeux c'est
bien ça ok j'ai compris ça va aller
ouais ok pas merci cette journée n'ont
rien mais ça donne moi ton portable et
pc les yeux mais non mais pas sûr bah
oui bah oui qui est conscient
[Musique]